meanwhile President Trump signing the
bipartisan eight point three billion
dollar Coronas virus eight bill this
week only two members of congress voted
against it my next guest it's one of
them Arizona of Republican congressman
Andy Biggs joins us now Congress of bigs
the first question is what the heck are
you thinking about yeah what I'm
thinking about is this thing has been
hyperbolized and the politicization that
has gone on
look the administration has done a good
job they said they needed two and a half
billion dollars both before and after
the vote that's what I said I would vote
for what happened is the Chuck Schumer
immediately politicized this took it up
to 6 1 and then the House Democrats took
it over 14 billion and they backed in to
the eight billion dollar money I'm out
and they're sending a billion and a half
of that overseas so I look at and I say
the administration has been consistent
they needed two and a half billion
dollars that's what we should do
we're in Congress if they come back
three weeks three months later whatever
it is and say you know we need another
five hundred million dollars or whatever
we can do it and just because it's the
right thing to do doesn't mean that you
you triple the amount of money that
should be put to to this effect because
the people are concerned there's a lot
of misinformation out there this remains
a low risk a low chance that you're
going to get this and people who do get
it for the vast majority of them it's
not going to be all those things
congressman but with all due respect 415
to to essentially sometimes you take a
political owl when it comes to something
as frightening as this because I'm with
you a thousand percent
I think the coverage has been overly you
know deliberately in fact to create a
certain amount of havoc in the stock
market and on Main Street but by the
same token you've mentioned coming back
to Congress that's the kind of
leadership people don't want to see
right now this is one of those rare
occasions where maybe being
over-prepared it's what the American
people want to see because the last
thing you want is for this to evolve to
a place where America the American
public says oh well we're caught
flat-footed we've got to go back to
Congress and let them muddle through the
next round of funding well I'm gonna
have to push back on that Charles just a
little bit the administration said they
need two and a half billion dollars they
also had a
funds from other sources that were in
there already and the fact of the matter
is you could have put a trigger in here
saying once you spin down a to a bid and
a half whatever your number is we're
going to trigger additional funding they
didn't do any of that this has not been
done because it's to prepare us this is
sending this money out three and five
years out this is not dealing with the
exigent circumstance and moving forward
with a plan
this is responding reacting in my
opinion perhaps overly recklessly
because of the spending you could have
done this in a very orderly way they
chose not to they chose to politicize it
yeah and that's what this that's what
that's why you get things like eight
billion dollars when you should have
done two and a half and if you need it
more you could have me listen I
understand a circumstance is down in DC
right now and this is why you know to
get our stronger defense you've got to
spend on extra things and we're why
everything that spiraled out of control
and a lot of people applaud you for
sticking to your own political
convictions it was a dangerous gambit in
some ways but let me just switch gears
here and ask you about this major change
now Mick Moe Amit mark Meadows rather in
as chief of staff how you feel about
that I think I think mix done a good job
I think mark will do a great job I'm
gonna miss him in Congress he is a great
friend and I think he's going to be a
tremendous asset to the White House and
to President Trump
quickly president Trump sending troops
to the border that's ahead of the
Supreme Court ruling a lot of people
concerned about this whole remain of
Mexico thing and perhaps before then our
rush to get him before the Supreme Court
is this the right move yes it is the
right move and and the the MPP program
is really worked and I'm hoping that the
courts understand that that is it's a
cooperative effort with with Mexico and
I think it's really been helpful
representative Biggs always a pleasure
to talk to you thank you very much